attention
3 240 accident quatre blessés
aujourd'hui le bilan sur notre opération
aujourd'hui
comment se préparer
eh bien
par la police comment vous n'aurez
qu'une panne
les manifestations ont pris fin
j'ai arrêté
en clair comment en estrie comprenant
les mégane dernier et qui est passible
de prison et d'amendé dans l'appartement
qu'il en soit l'avortement mais la
polémique
le comité que c'est avant tout un
appartement dont 80
encore call
comme ici ramallah enfermer chez les
accrochages
la partie comme très vite on a parlé de
traque les moteurs par an
la semaine dernière
librement
impressions
nous sommes à trois
cette dernière manche